you know we send people off to war and
potentially die for this country and so
we as civilians as a country need to
understand what we're truly demanding of
them
this project began back in 1998 so i've
been doing this for about 16 years and
it was really inspired by a fire that we
had in our house in washington dc
everything we had was destroyed and i
had no military connections before this
i had no interest in history before this
but when we lost all of our family
memorabilia it just made me realize how
important it is to preserve our past and
i started talking with veterans just by
coincidence and so many of them said oh
you know i threw all my letters away
and i was just so shocked that they
would do that so carol a d.c dc-based
author and historian decided to do
something to save the letters which
provide the most intimate records of war
from the perspective of the men and
women who actually fight them i wrote to
dear abby who has a syndicated column
across the country and she wrote a lot
about veterans issues and i said could
you do a column encouraging your readers
to send in any war letters they might
have so we can preserve them and it's
like the floodgates opened we just got
thousands and thousands of responses
from people this project has preserved
over a hundred thousand letters ranging
from a revolutionary war all the way to
the war on terror being a private
organization really made this a much
more personal project both for me and
for the people who are sending in
letters they're not sending into some
government bureaucracy they're sending
it to people who respond to them
personally who read every letter carol
recently donated his collection to
chapman university and the university is
in the process of digitizing the letters
and making them more readily available
to the public chapman has also
incorporated the letters into their
educational studies the university's
goal is to become the nation's most
prominent archive of personal wartime
correspondences the history that these
letters capture is incredible whether
they're written from gettysburg or from
caisson or antietam or any of these
major battles and they humanize the men
and women who wrote them so we no longer
see them as just soldiers airmen marines
and sailors but as somebody's spouse or
child or parent or best friend we have a
letter by a young man who's inside a
ship at pearl harbor as the bombs are
falling and he's trapped in the ford
engine room and so he's writing to his
sister like you know it's been it's 905
a.m sunday morning the bomb has been
dropping for an hour
we're trapped here in the ship and you
look at the upper right hand corner
since december 7 1941 uss new orleans
like i got chills when i first saw that
because here he is
literally you know in the eye of the
storm we as civilians who you know elect
certain leaders and you know rally
behind a war need to know what these
troops are going to have to sacrifice
and give up the more that we have a
sense that these are actual individuals
that we're sending off to fight i think
it's better for the entire country it's
better for the military it's better for
all of us
you